hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren ich darf euch heute
endlich mal wieder nach Jahren herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einer neuen Episode
mit Luca und zur Feier des Tages habe
ich mir für heute etwas Besonderes
überlegt denn ich habe hier ein Schild
vorbereitet auf dem drauf steht ich
hä in der Kamera ist das richtig
geschrieben aber hier ist das
spielverkehrt
auf meinem Schild steht auf jeden Fall
drauf ich rede erst wenn du mich zum
lachen bringst habe ich auch schon den
Titel geschrieben und das werde ich
gleich so halten
und ja mal schauen ob ich irgendwas zum
Lachen bringen kann
oh mein Gott
gar kein Vertrauen in ihrem Humor ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
ich musste erstmal wieder reinkommen
Idiot ich habe aus Affekt irgendwie auf
Reaktion gedrückt
Luca bist du ich habe gerade deine
Instagram Story gesehen und mir direkt
die obet TV App runtergeladen man
ich wollte eigentlich erst reden wenn
mich mal zum Lachen bringen aber ich
kann einfach nicht nicht lachen glaube
ich
Carlos
oh mein Gott allein dafür muss ich dich
blockieren eigentlich
schwöre wie soll ich dich zum Lachen
bringen wenn du das Schild vor deinem
Tisch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bestimmt
hallo bitte sag mal was ich rede erst
wenn du mich zum lachen bringst
[Musik]
ich weiß trotzdem
ja okay das ist von Youtube Video ich
würde du kannst andere Leute verarschen
nicht mich das ist der nicht junge
halten
oder bitte einmal winken ich bin dein
größter Fan bist du gar nicht
ey kannst du bitte noch mal winken
junge das ist wirklich schlecht
nee mach mal so
mach bitte komm wenn du Ehre hast mach
einmal so bitte nein bist du jetzt
wirklich Laser Luca nee ich verarsche
euch
du bist jetzt wirklich
gemacht dass Leute ja ey
no joke
ich habe mich bei den beiden gerade echt
gefühlt wie so ein Tier im Zirkus was
durch so ein Ring springen soll oder so
mal schauen ob ich die nächste Person
zum Lachen bringen kann
[Musik]
okay
trotzdem gelacht aber er ist ein
ziemlich weggedrückt hat er sagt dir
einfach okay tschüss wir haben alle gar
kein Vertrauen in ihren Humor oder so
warum bin ich denn so wenn ich
Langeweile hätte mit Kollegen auf dieser
Plattform wäre und jemand für das hier
machen ey wir würden alle versuchen
irgendwie ein Salto zu machen oder
irgendwie ein Schwachsinn zu erzählen
oder so aber niemand redet hier
irgendwie okay okay
Jungs schaut mal mein Stream wir haben
ja einen ganz übel in Knechte mich zum
lachen bringst let's go sitzen zwei
Hochhäuser im Keller und spielen Mau-Mau
kommt ein grünes Pferd aus der Steckdose
und sagt morgen ist Silvester aber ich
gehe nicht hin
ich bringe dich nicht zum Lachen ich bin
nicht lustig auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ich habe halt vor dem Video überlegt
zeige ich mein Gesicht dabei also mache
ich es quasi so weil also ihr seht mich
ja in dieser Ansicht aber die Leute
sehen mich so ich habe hier eine zweite
Kamera aufgebaut damit ich die halt
benutzen kann damit man mich halt dann
komplett sehen kann aber ich habe mir
dann gedacht wenn ich mein Gesicht sehen
könnte es sein dass sie mich kennen und
dann konzentrieren die sich nämlich auf
Schild da muss ich automatisch Lachen
deswegen wollte ich halt so machen ich
werde jetzt noch einmal so probieren
was warte das ist weißt du was Ronaldos
Lieblingsfrucht ist Zitronen
nein Orangen
keine Ahnung die hat einfach meinen Witz
geklaut
das hat
Millionen von aufrufen gesammelt ich
blende euch hier mal ein Lieblingsfrucht
von Cristiano Ronaldo boah ich denke mal
Wassermelone
sie hat diesen Witz zu 99% von Sandra
und mir klaut den und will den bei mir
benutzen
und dann drückt die mich weg ich rede
erst wenn du mich zum lachen bringst
okay geht
ja okay ich kenne genau
rot und hat zwei Träger eine Tomaten mit
einem Rosen eingezogen
oh mein Gott ich habe für mich mal eine
Sekunde meine Augen gezeigt
und die wussten das schon deswegen ich
muss das Schild von meinem Kopf halten
glaube ich leise lachen ja so ich muss
ich muss schon laut lachen du hast
geredet
[Musik]
das heißt Laser
von Youtube ja gut dann viel Spaß schöne
Ferien
Schluss eigentlich das heutige Video
weil der damaligen und deswegen würde
ich aber ja
logischer Abschluss war dann würde ich
jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat
das Youtuber von hinten sich gedacht hat
ey ich komme mal eure ganzen Nachrichten
nach und lade mal wieder TV hoch dann
lass deinen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weitere Videos nichts
verpassen schreibt mir unten in die
Kommentare was ich im nächsten Moment TV
Video machen soll ich zeige mich erst
wenn du beende diesen Satz unten in die
Kommentaren die heutige Challenge
hiermit hat nicht so gut funktioniert
aber tun wir mal so als hätte
die wurden vom chatverband Grund
irrelevantes Bild ich bin für
Stunden gebannt oder ich bezahle um den
Bann auf
Fehler seid ihr am Arsch okay
frühestens 33 Stunden